[Musique]
parfois rendre hommage est une nécessité
pour sa famille ses collègues et toute
la réunion
le service départemental d'incendié et
de secours a rendu un hommage funèbre à
l'adjudant eve à la caserne de
saint-andré
pas du danger si est au nom du président
de la république et en vertu des
pouvoirs qui nous sont les visages sont
fermés mais deux ont tenu à être
présents pour leurs collègues
sa dernière intervention sur la route
nationale 2 résume les valeurs de ce
corps qui son courage et dévouement
une communion plein de douleur
localement 2575 sapeurs pompiers
interviennent plus de 50 de 1400 fois
par an un engagement qui a du sens d'un
métier un métier difficile qui mérite
toute notre reconnaissance
parce qu'être sapeurs pompiers
professionnels ou volontaires
ces savoir faire preuve de dévouement
d'habitation et toutes ses qualités ben
le sapeurs-pompiers décédés les avait et
encore une fois à l'ensemble des
sapeurs-pompiers de la réunion je
renouvelle mon soutien et la
reconnaissance du département à toutes
celles et ceux qui travaillent au
quotidien quoi assurer
la sécurité de nos concitoyens
[Musique]
après plusieurs remises de décoration à
titre posthume et notamment la légion
d'honneur
chacun a pu échanger comprendre pour à
nouveau avancer ensemble nous devenions
sapeurs pompiers principalement par
altruisme et je pense que notre collègue
l'adjudant eve aurait souhaité bien sûr
pour
un hommage lui sera rendu que sa famille
soit soutenue et je pense là ses enfants
bien son épouse
mais que nous continuons tous ensemble à
mener cette démission et celle du
service à la population
une cérémonie religieuse a conclu ce
moment de deuil de ses héros des temps
modernes qui se consacrent chaque jour à
l'autre
[Musique]